do you see this world where
just everything's a competing surface
you see that possibility
just everything's a computer yeah i
don't see any reason that that
couldn't be achieved it turns out that
sand goes into
glass and glass is pretty useful too
and you know like why not why not
so the very important question then
if um if we're
living in a simulation and uh the
simulation is running a computer
like what what's the architecture of
that computer do you think
um so you're saying is it a uh quantum
system
is it yeah like this whole quantum
discussion is it needed or can
can we run it on a you know with a risk
five architecture
uh a bunch of cpus i think it comes down
to the right tool for the job
yeah and so and what's the pilot yeah
exactly that's
that's my question how do i get that job
made the universe compiler
um uh and so they're
as far as we know quantum quantum
quantum systems are the bottom of the
pile of turtles so far yeah
and so we don't know efficient ways to
implement quantum systems without using
quorum computers
yeah and that's totally outside of
everything we've talked about but who
runs that quantum computer
yeah right so if it if we really are
living in a simulation
then is it bigger quantum computers is
it different ones like
how does that work out how does that
scale well it's it's the same size
it's the same size but then but then the
thought of the simulation is that you
don't have to run
the whole thing that you know we humans
are cognitively very limited checkpoints
checkpoints yeah and uh and
if we the point at which we human so you
basically do minimal
amount of uh what is it uh the swift
does um
on right copy copy down right yeah so
you only
yeah you only adjust the simulation
every parallel universe theories right
and so
and so every time a decision is made
yeah somebody opens the short in your
box then
there's a fork and then this could
happen and then uh
thank you for uh for considering the
possibility but yeah so it
may not require you know the entirety of
the universe to simulate it
but it's um interesting to think about
as we create this this higher and higher
fidelity
systems but i do want to ask on the on
the quantum computer side because
everything we've talked about
with us whether you work with sci-fi
with everything with compilers
none of that includes quantum computers
right that's true
so if you ever thought
about uh what a you know this whole
serious
engineering work of quantum computers
looks like of compilers
of architectures all that kind of stuff
so i've looked at a little bit i'd know
almost nothing about it which means that
at some point i will have to find an
excuse to get involved
because that's what do you think do you
think that's the thing to be
like is with your little tingly senses
of the timing of want to be involved
is it not yet well so so the thing i do
really well is
i jump into messy systems and figure out
how to make them
figure out what the truth in the
situation is to try to figure out what
what the unifying theory is how to like
factor the complexity how to find a
beautiful answer to a problem that
has been well studied and lots of people
have bashed their heads against it
i don't know that quantum computers are
mature enough and accessible enough to
be
um they figured out yet right and
um the uh i think the open question with
quantum computers is is there
a useful problem that gets solved with a
quantum computer
that makes it worth the economic cost of
like having one of these things and
having
having legions of people that that that
uh set it up
you go back to the 50s right and there's
the projections of the world can we only
need
seven seven computers right well and
part of that was
that people hadn't figured out what
they're useful for yeah what are the
algorithms we want to run what do the
problems get solved and this comes back
to
how do we make the world better either
economically or making somebody's life
better
or like solving a problem that wasn't
solved before things like this
and um i think that just we're a little
bit too early in that development cycle
because it's still like literally a
science project
not a negative connotation right it's
literally a science project and
um the progress there's amazing and so i
don't know if it's
10 years away if it's two years away
exactly where that breakthrough happens
but
um you look at machine learning it
we went through a few winners um before
the alex net transition
and then suddenly it had its breakout
moment and that was the catalyst that
then drove
the talent flocking into it that's what
drove the economic
applications of it that's what drove the
um the technology to go faster because
you now have more minds thrown at the
problem
this is what caused like a serious knee
in
deep learning and the algorithms that
we're using and
um and so i think that's what quantum
needs to go through and so right now
it's in that that formidable
finding itself getting the the like
literally the physics
figured out and um and then and then it
has to figure out the application that
makes uh that's useful
yeah right now i'm i'm not skeptical
that i think that will happen i think
it's just you know
10 years away something like that i
forgot to ask what
programming language do you think the
simulation is written in
oh probably lisp
so not swift like if you were to pay you
were the best uh
you